you can't have a standard education and
expect to have an extraordinary life
it's not gonna happen so I'm gonna give
you a three step process to how to
create a customized program for you so
that you can become world-class at the
thing that you want to be world class
you are all hopelessly average by birth
we all are and that's the great news
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right to get there grab your coffee
and sip on today's message constantly
improve yourself over to you tony
robbins also if you want to know what
tony robbins and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days
i will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence to
link the join is in the description
below the fact that human beings our
strongest drive is the need to stay
consistent with how we define ourselves
so while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions so if
you want to change your life my friends
you've got to change your physiology and
you got to change your focus but you
can't have a standard education and
expect to have an extraordinary life
it's not gonna happen
the one breakthrough for all leaders is
constant never-ending improvement and
that means educating yourself and
continuing to develop even greater
emotional mastery because that's what
affects whether you execute enough the
opportunity for self education is there
we have to change our psychology from
i'm gonna do what everybody else does
and i'm mad because it doesn't work
anymore - the reality is this the
greatest time to be alive if you're
growing you're learning you're educating
and you're developing valuable skills so
instead of complaining you gotta say
where are the skill sets valued in the
marketplace and how do i work harder on
myself than anything else because if i
become more valuable then i will be able
to give more do more and change more my
interviewed warren buffett asked the
most important investment you ever made
in his life you already said it was i
was thinking all the companies they've
done you know he said tony going to dale
carnegie said what he goes because by
developing myself that's the most
important investment those skill sets
learning how to persuade learning how to
speak learning and influence all my
ideas would've died on my lips
if I hadn't be able to influence and I
learned it from that little course most
valuable thing ever did my life he said
self-improvement is the answer to
whatever obstacle is staring you in the
face right now the only difference
between you and greatness is the
willingness to grow and improve it's not
talent it's not smart it's the
willingness to improve yourself the
difference between you and Tony Robbins
is he has spent more time constantly
improving himself than most people on
the planet here's a guy who had multiple
fathers growing up had an abusive mother
who had 17 he had to run away from home
so he could become a janitor and never
go to college he then decided to be a
success he read 700 books in seven years
he studied under mentors like Jim Rohn
and today he's the founder or owner of
companies with over six billion dollars
in annual revenue if Tony Robbins can go
from being an abused janitor with no
college education to being one of the
most influential people in the world why
can't you the difference is he made the
investment to constantly improve himself
and you haven't yet at that level so I
look at my channel as an example my
youtube channel and I've learned so much
over the past number of years in
confidence and growth and abilities and
skills by consuming the content because
I love the top 10 series in the men t'me
series in the answer vs. series I make
them for me and then I share them with
you and thankfully you guys like them
too and I can build a business off of it
and keep pumping out more content but it
helps me
I've grown I've learned and one of the
biggest moments that helped me realize
how much I've learned is when I signed a
three-year deal with sage I was working
with Stephen Kelly who was the CEO and
every month we'd be on a call we'd be
doing a hangout on my YouTube channel
answering questions from people and I
was driving with my dad and I remember
him asking me
how do you get the confidence to be on a
call with Stephen Kelly and be seen as
his equal all the time and he wasn't
asking me to put me down he was asking
me in ingenuine of he was so happy for
me that I was playing a bigger game and
it dawned on me that he was right the
Evan of five years ago wouldn't have
been able to do that the Evan of five
years ago would have felt less than the
Evan of five years ago would have said
there's no way I'm capable of doing that
and then when I'd signed the deal I felt
like it's great I love Stephen he's
amazing but I feel like I'm hanging out
with Oprah and Kanye and Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates and these super successful
people and they're infiltrating my brain
on a daily basis right a daily basis
three videos every single day on this
channel and so bit by bit it pulls me up
now I've recognized I still have a long
way to go I still have so much more to
learn I still need to believe in myself
even more and every time I consume more
content it allows me to grow my comfort
zone a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit more and the funny
thing is all of these moments are little
tiny incremental parts of your growth
I couldn't point you to one point in my
past where I said that was the moment
that I changed that was the moment that
I had more confidence but as I studied
every day every day every day I could
look back three months six months a year
and say wow I've really changed I've
really grown I've really learned a lot
but in the daily from today the
yesterday I'd say I didn't grow at all
and so sometimes on your journeys are
trying to learn and get better you may
feel like the growth is really slow on a
daily basis but if you keep going you
keep investing you keep learning you
keep seeking out mentors you keep trying
to get better and improve not every day
will be amazing but if you try every day
to get better and learn I can guarantee
you that in three months six months one
year when you look back of the person
you've become compared to what you are
right now there'll be a big change and
that's because you continue to invest in
yourself so I'm going to give you a
3-step process to how to create a
customized program for you so that you
can become world-class at the thing that
you want to be world-class at step 1
decide what you want to be world-class
at you could be world-class at a lot of
things with enough and
effort wisdom porn into you practice
repetition you can be world-class at
something but what what like what in
your core what is the thing that you
need to be world-class at what is the
burning desire in you that you say I
want to be among the best in the world
at what fill that in what do you want to
be world-class at number two immerse
yourself in that environment the fastest
way to learn a language the fastest way
to learn Japanese is not from a textbook
it's not from going to classes it's to
go to Japan you need to immerse yourself
in the environment whatever the thing is
that you want to be great at the more
you are around it people who are doing
it people who are speaking at people who
are living it the more it will rub off
on to you and the faster it will rub off
on to you now it can be a physical
environment or could also be from the
content that you're consuming I get it a
lot from my own YouTube videos because I
feel like I'm around Steve Jobs and Elon
Musk and Oprah Winfrey every single day
and the more you immerse yourself in
that environment the more their mindset
the more their motivation the more their
confidence is gonna stick with you to
help you go be world-class the thing
that you want to be great at and then
step number three is practice every
single day you need to practice every
single day it's not enough just to be
around it you need to practice you got
to do you want to be world-class at
something right that requires daily
dedication the reason why I got better
at making my content my videos is I've
done 6,000 videos a thousand videos
aren't even public on my channel we've
thrown away more videos and most people
ever create on their channel and it's
not because I'm amazing go back like I
encourage you go back and look at my
first videos I sucked it was brutal it's
because I said I want to be great at
this thing and I surround myself with
people who could help push me and I
could learn from and then I practice
every single day the reason why I pass
people who are considered to be a lot
better than me at this is because I put
in more work because when people had a
hard time finding time to make one video
a week I was doing 3 a day and if you
take that same approach if you take that
same mindset up I'm just gonna outwork
everybody around me I'm gonna outwork my
competition when they may have a hard
time finding time to do
that thing that they need to get better
at once a week and you're doing it three
times a day you will blow past people
who are more naturally talented because
you have put in the work that get good
at your skill now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but first question of the
day I want to know what is the one area
of your life that you want to improve
most let me know put in the comments
below
you are all hopelessly average by birth
we all are and that's the great news
because the most important thing to
understand about the human species we
are the ultimate adaptation machine if
you guys were paying attention not too
long ago they sequenced the human genome
and they realized that the human genome
has 20,000 genes and everybody they
thought that they were going to cure
cancer all the diseases age-related
disease everything type 1 type type type
2 diabetes is all gonna be a thing of
the past we're gonna have it figured out
and then we realized that an onion has
more genetic diversity than we do and
how could that be and so they're
literally going is this really possible
do we misunderstand something like how
is it that an onion has more genetic
diversity than we have and somebody
finally said hey maybe all this stuff
that we've been referring to as junk DNA
maybe it actually plays a role and then
they began to realize that all that junk
DNA that was outside of those 20,000
genes we saw expressing themselves is
what is called epigenetics now if you've
ever heard of epigenetics that's amazing
you're way ahead if you haven't heard of
epigenetics let it become one of the
most important things in your life
because epigenetics is what has made us
the most dominant species this planet
has ever seen it is the only thing that
you need to know it's what I call the
only belief that matters the only belief
that matters is that you can learn
anything I don't need you to believe
that you're good now that doesn't matter
who you are now is totally irrelevant
the only thing I want to know who are
you willing to become and what's the
price you're willing to pay to get there
and that's what humans are designed to
do if you put us under stress we can
learn something new we can get better if
I want to do something I find somebody
that's already done it and then I do
exactly what they tell me it's a simple
rule to follow I I don't read novels
I don't watch movies I'd watch
documentaries or things like that where
I can learn and I'm only interested in
studying something that can cause me to
become more of what I'm capable of being
see I think we're all hardwired to do
something really special with their life
and that's all I want to do I'm really
good at what I do I could walk by a
person in the hall like that I could
tell them exactly what they're like I
could read their energy like a book
everything goes on the inside shows on
the outside
see we're gifted with with faculties of
the mind that the average person knows
nothing about your vid tuition the will
reason imagine a ssin perception memory
that's what separates us from all the
rest of forms of life we go through
school never learn anything about it but
you'll hear people say they have a bad
memory there's no such thing as a bad
memory everybody has a perfect memory
it's just weak they've never developed
it our imagination your imagination is
the most magnificent piece he'll said
it's the most marvelous miraculous
inconceivably powerful force the world's
ever known
I can use my imagination to project
myself into the future and bring the
future into the present and start living
there you work from the imagination you
don't work to it you work from it
backwards from the result yeah and if
you want more Tony Robbins check out the
eight hours of Tony Robbins motivation
video I made the link is right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there one of the biggest challenges for
people's everybody wants a better
quality of life
everybody wants life to be greater but
almost all of us get stuck at times